vamos a regresar a nuestro puesto de
tacos y recordemos que esto de aquí era
una curva de demanda ahorita lo que
quiero hacer es pensar en términos del
ingreso total para entonces aquí le voy
a poner ingreso ingreso total total y
ahorita pues por simplicidad vamos a
pensar que solo nos importa el ingreso
total de ventas de tacos vale ok
entonces como le haríamos para calcular
el ingreso total antes simplemente el
ingreso total sería igual al precio por
la cantidad de tacos que se venden si
verdad si se venden digamos 50 tacos y
cada uno cuesta 5 pesos esto entonces se
ganan 50 por 5 que es igual a 250 bueno
eso es lo que se tiene de ingreso luego
hay que quitar los gastos de asís pero
al menos el ingreso total sería de 250
pesos muy bien entonces lo que quiero
hacer ahorita es ver cómo se vería el
ingreso total en distintos puntos según
lo que nos dice nuestra curva de demanda
entonces vamos a hacer una tabla por acá
va entonces déjame ponerle
aquí una tabla de ingreso total le voy a
poner así precio voy a poner cantidad y
le voy a poner ingreso total y aquí voy
a poner algunas situaciones de precio
aquí algunas situaciones de cantidad
aunque sabes que ya que tenemos toda
esta información que ya está escrita
aquí pues vamos a utilizar exactamente
estos mismos escenarios entonces aquí en
precio cantidad de ingreso total
voy a ir haciendo cada uno de estos
casos y vamos a ver cuánto nos da de
ingreso total muy bien entonces vamos a
empezar con a lo voy a poner del color
de a entonces vamos a empezar con a en a
tenemos un precio de 9 y se venden dos
tacos 99 pesos y se venden dos tacos
cuerdas que esto es pesos y esto es
tacos por hora entonces cuál sería el
ingreso total este es ingreso total por
hora verdad porque estos tacos por hora
entonces cuál sería el ingreso total de
esa hora pues si están a 9 y se venden
29 por 12 18 18 ahora lo interesante es
que hay una forma pues visual de
interpretar este 18 de interpretar esta
multiplicación también podemos pensar
este 18 este ingreso total como
como el área que nos da el rectángulo
que tiene como esquina el punto y
entonces déjame bajar así para que
llegue más o menos a 2 que es la
cantidad que se venden entonces como
tenemos la multiplicación 9 por 2 es lo
mismo que hacer esta altura que vale 9
por este largo que mide 2 entonces es lo
mismo que obtener esta área de acá
entonces lo de ingreso total de a es el
área que tenemos con el rectángulo con
punto superior derecho en a muy bien
vamos a pasar a ver ahora vamos con ve
lo voy a poner con este color que es el
color de ve que es 8 y la cantidad es 4
34 entonces abre el ingreso total es 32
observes 4 x 8 32 verdad y observa como
aumentó de 18 pasamos a 32 otra vez
podemos interpretar esto como un área
aquí marcamos el 8 más o menos aquí
bajamos
más o menos así y entonces ahora el
ingreso total sería esta área verdad ojo
también abarca tantito del área rosa es
todo esto de acá bueno vámonos al
siguiente el siguiente se que el precio
de 550 550 y de cantidad tenemos 9
entonces 550 por 9 pues 9 por 5 es 45 y
9 por 50 centavos es 450 entonces es 45
450 es 49 pesos con 50 centavos va a
este es el ingreso total por ahora
entonces ahora tendríamos un área de
este estilo 550 es como por acá y ahora
la cantidad es 9 que es como por acá muy
bien y ahora el área que tenemos es
estable acá excelente
entonces observa la tendencia parece ser
que que va aumentando el ingreso total
será esto cierto siempre pues vamos a
seguir averiguando vámonos al punto de
el punto de ahora es 450 por 11 450 por
10 es 45 y si esos 45 le sumamos este 1
por 450 o sea otros 450 nos da 49 50
déjame bajar tantito para que quepa
entonces aquí es 450 450 y el precio es
perdón la cantidad de es 11 entonces
otra vez tenemos 49 50 450 por 11 49 50
entonces al menos aquí ya no aumentó
verdad déjame lo marcó como área
por aquí está 11 más o menos es esta
área de acá bueno entonces aquí un
aumento que va a pasar en el siguiente
paso pues en el siguiente paso ahora
tenemos 2 y 16 que le pongo un 2 y 16 2
por 16 32 y observa observa aquí pasó
algo interesante ahora el ingreso total
el ingreso total por la venta de tacos
no no aumentó sino que ahora disminuyó
ahorita vamos a hacer una gráfica para
analizar eso sale nada más déjame y
ahora pongo este rectángulo ahora
tenemos esta esta base verdad y esta
altura esta altura es más pequeña es una
altura de 2
que tiene esta área es la misma que el
área de verdad porque el área debe
también era 32 y finalmente déjame
indicar con azul un poco más claro la
situación con efe si quieres ir haciendo
la multiplicación en lo que dibujó el
rectángulo tenemos algo así tenemos que
calcular esta área de acá cuya altura es
1 y su largo el 18 que es 1 y 18 y
entonces tenemos un ingreso total de 18
de 18 muy bien entonces disminuyó ok
esto está interesante verdad o sea como
que al parecer el precio el ingreso
total aumenta aumenta aumenta y luego
disminuye vamos a dibujar una gráfica de
lo vamos a poner cantidad contra ingreso
total para ver qué podemos decir al
respecto a lo mejor nos queda algún poco
bonito entonces la voy a poner por acá
entonces esta gráfica nos va a ayudar a
interpretar un poco mejor esta
información aquí voy a poner la flechita
aquí otra flechita cantidad llega como
hasta 20 déjame marcar que por aquí está
10 más o menos y habitando haciendo las
cosas un poco esbozadas a lo mejor no
quedan muy bonitas pero vamos a ver en
este eje tenemos que poner ingreso total
que es ingreso total aquí abajo es
cantidad entonces de la cantidad de
tacos ahora pero este ingreso total este
ingreso total este pues aquí lo tenemos
y está en pesos por ahora pero lo
importante es saber hasta dónde llega
más o menos la altura verdad para
poderlo marcarlo aquí en el eje entonces
aquí tenemos como que hasta 50 aquí voy
a poner 50 si este 50 a quien medios 25
pero déjame marcar más o menos por aquí
40 acá 30 20 y 10 más o menos más o
menos algo de este estilo bueno ya con
estos puntos vamos a ver qué nos queda
esta gráfica de acá entonces tenemos que
cuando la cantidad es 2 se venden 18 es
más o menos como por acá bueno más o
menos cupo voy a poner un poco más a la
derecha es como a la quinta parte de 10
verdad luego cuando la cantidad es 4 el
ingreso total es 32
entonces ahora es como por acá es 32 más
o menos luego cuando la cantidad es 9 el
ingreso total es 49.5
esto es muy alto
y luego va bajando cuando ves 11 también
es 49.5 y conforme nos vamos acercando a
20 sigue disminuyendo ahora tenemos este
color azul de acá otra vez llegamos a 32
que es para 16 entonces algo de este
estilo y finalmente en este color azul
si tenemos 18 tacos vendidos por ahora
entonces el ingreso total es de 18 por
ahí esto de aquí queda muy simétrico
verdad de hecho si conectaremos los
puntos y conectaremos los puntos bueno a
lo mejor necesitamos una mejor gráfica
pero podríamos ver que esto es más o
menos una parábola
es una parábola y tiene que ver con qué
con qué cómo está definida esta curva de
demanda sí con que sea lineal entonces
aquí nos quedaría una parábola y por acá
tendríamos un punto óptimo verdad la
mejor cantidad de tacos que podemos
vender para obtener pues el mayor
ingreso total creo que sería más o menos
10 aquí si tenemos 10 habría que ver
cuánto nos da acá yo creo que 5 pesos
entonces ganamos 50 más o menos que es
un poquito más que éste 49.5 pero ahora
te has de estar preguntando por qué
estamos viendo esto en la lista de
elasticidad de demanda si pudimos hablar
del ingreso total independientemente
bueno lo que está padre es que hay una
relación muy interesante mira vamos a
explorar la elasticidad de nuevo y a
intentar relacionarla con el ingreso
total entonces al principio vimos que el
ingreso total aumenta y luego disminuye
y con la elasticidad pasaba algo similar
verdad al principio la elasticidad era
mayor que 1 déjame apuntarlo para
acordarnos acá cuando pasamos de aaa ve
la elasticidad era era mayor a 1
la elasticidad de la demanda era mayor a
1 luego de c&a de la elasticidad de la
demanda en valor absoluto era igual a 1
y acá abajo teníamos que la elasticidad
de la demanda era menor que 1 y habíamos
dicho que aquí decíamos que era elástico
elástico aquí era elasticidad unitaria
elasticidad unitaria y finalmente aquí
abajo decíamos que era un elástico
inelástico vale en este caso de acá
este cachito de acá y este cachito de
acá entonces vamos parte vamos paso a
paso que sucede aquí arriba cuando el
bien es elástico pues cuando el bien es
elástico en este cambio de acá de a ave
pues justo un cambio en el precio con
una disminución del precio nos está
causando que el ingreso total aumente
eso de allí está interesante verdad
ahora vámonos más o menos aquí en medio
aquí en medio teníamos una elasticidad
unitaria y con esta elasticidad unitaria
que sucede ahora si vemos esa misma
región en términos del ingreso total
pues ahora el ingreso total de 49.5 se
pasó a 49 puntos
entonces aquí en esta región de
elasticidad unitaria no hubo cambio de
ingreso total eso también empieza a
sonar un poco sospechoso verdad
finalmente aquí abajo cuando él viene
era inelástico cuando la elasticidad de
la demanda era menor que 1 entonces pues
no salió que el ingreso total disminuye
entonces esto está como que como que
interesante verdad déjame escribirlo por
acá para para resumirlo esto parece ser
un fenómeno general lo voy a poner con
este color rosa y entonces básicamente
tenemos lo siguiente cuando el bien es
elástico y elástico
esto básicamente quiere decir que la
elasticidad de la demanda es mayor que 1
entonces una baja en el precio una baja
en el precio que hace pues hace que el
ingreso total aumente va entonces
elástico bajen el precio hace que el
ingreso total aumente vámonos al medio
en medio cuando tenemos elasticidad
unitaria elasticidad unitaria es decir
cuando la elasticidad de la demanda es
igual a 1 en valor absoluto una baja en
el precio una baja en el precio que hace
pues hace que el ingreso total
permanezca constante ingreso total
permanezca constante le van a poner así
más o menos constante después platicamos
que hay que tener unas cosas más en
cuenta pero después lo vemos y
finalmente cuando la elasticidad o
vuelvo a poner aquí cuando es inelástico
inelástico
cuando es inelástico entonces tenemos
que la elasticidad de la demanda es
menor que 1 y una baja en el precio
ahora ya no nos aumenta el ingreso total
sino que hace que el ingreso total
disminuya y vamos a pensar porque esto
de aquí es más o menos intuitivo
pues mira si tenemos que el bien es
elástico entonces un cambio porcentual y
un cambio porcentual en el precio pues
va a ser más pequeño que el cambio
porcentual en la cantidad justo eso es
que el bien sea elástico verdad que la
elasticidad de la demanda en valor
absoluto sea mayor que 1 es que el
cambio porcentual que el cambio
porcentual cambio porcentual de la
cantidad entre el cambio porcentual del
precio sea mayor que 1 entonces un
pequeño cambio en porcentual está
compensado por un mayor cambio en la
cantidad y por tanto qué sucede con el
área pues si cambiamos tantito la
longitud está si la hacemos más chiquita
pero hacemos proporcionalmente más
grande la cantidad entonces vamos a
aumentar el área de modo similar una
elasticidad unitaria nos dice que el
cambio proporcional de precio y cantidad
es el mismo entonces más o menos el
cambio de precio y cantidad es el mismo
o sea ya
sin proporcional y entonces el área
permanece igual y disminuyó nuestra
altura pero de manera similar o más o
menos por la misma cantidad aumentó la
longitud y por eso el área se queda
igual y finalmente si el bienes
inelásticos entonces pues que sucede
ahora lo que hacemos es disminuir el
precio en un porcentaje y aumentamos la
cantidad de nuestro porcentaje pero la
cantidad que aumentamos ahora es menor y
por tanto va disminuyendo esta área